so those are three aspects of what
scientism is and now we're going to the
history real quick and the reason I'm
trying to go so fast is because I want
to leave a lot of room for discussion
because we don't have much time
the subject that I'm teaching you guys I
I learn myself
for several years so I'm giving you as
much information as I can within this
period of time so that we can have open
discussion and really go through these
things
uh and flesh them out
so life of scientism now we're gonna go
into the history and I think you guys
are going to really find this
fascinating because I love the history
of Science and History of philosophy in
general because it tells you a lot about
how we think and how we got to where we
were or where we are today
so let's start with another awesome
graphic boom boom and this guy named
Frederick Hayek died in 1992 uh
sociologist also philosopher and he was
the first one to really coin what
scientism was uh he noticed there was a
big trend
um
should I answer this question
I will answer that later brother
Muhammad
don't worry I'll get to you okay so
Frederick Hayek was really the one to
kind of crystallized the definition of
scientism you don't have to write all
this down but if you want to that'd be
great I don't know how fast you guys are
in typing
I'm pretty good at it
um
it's because all I do is sit in a desk
all day
Okay so
no scientism is believed to have been
understood in practice in some form
since the 17th century by the French
and that's something you should know is
that the French were actually the first
ones to come up with with positivism as
well
get to that later the concept and the
term used to describe it was said to
have been crystallized by the
sociologist Frederick Hayek
and I quote him from the
counter-revolution of science studies of
the abuse of reason he States it needs
scarcely be emphasized that nothing we
shall have to say is aimed against the
methods of Science in the proposphere OR
intended to throw the slightest doubt on
their value but to preclude any
misunderstanding on this point we shall
wherever we are concerned not with the
general Spirit of disinterested inquiry
but with slavish imitation the method
language of science
speak of scientism more than scientific
Prejudice I'll explain all this later
don't worry
it should be noted that in the sense in
which we shall use these terms they
describe or of course an attitude which
is decidedly unscientific in the true
sense of a word since it involves a
mechanical and uncritical application of
habits of thoughts to feels different
from those of which they have been
formed
okay uh translation
he what he's saying here is that during
his time
there was a trend in which people were
taking the Natural Sciences
okay such as the theory of evolution
and applying it to Fields outside of the
scientific realm such as sociology which
project was a part of
and history so there were actually
people who were coming up with
theories of history based on evolution
okay
things like that
people coming up with Concepts such as
the French at the time during the
French Empire
who are coming up with Concepts about
Humanity
and a lot of racism was going on during
this time a lot of colonialism was being
justified through the use of
evolutionary Concepts
for instance Africans were seen as below
everyone else
um white people were seen as the highest
form of evolutionary animal
okay and Frederick Hayek was basically
like saying hey uh no bad idea that's
not how you're supposed to apply this
okay there's a big difference between
you know
my field of study how humans interact
with each other how humans you know
construct ideas and cultures and
societies and your understanding of the
natural process of the world okay you
need to back off
that's basically what he was trying to
point out okay
part of my my bloodness
um but you know I'm trying to give you
guys concise uh
form of this so that's what he was
basically saying so he's the first one
to kind of point this out and say okay
this is this is an issue uh and we need
to stop
now
did other people see it as well before
him yes but he was really the first one
to kind of really Define it and
crystallize it
I think in French it was called
scientist me but uh
I can't do a good French accent
so let's move on to another interesting
figure
Carl popper
Carl popper uh British philosopher
philosopher of science came up with the
concept of falsification you hear this
probably among atheists all the time you
can can you falsify that he's the one
who came up with this so blame him
1994 but he was he was an interesting
gentleman
let's see what do you say serial call
Papa a contemporary of Hayek would
eventually become a main actor in a
historical debate over the nature of
science which we will discuss later
mostly agreed with the former's
definition
though he would admit to being a
follower of scientism himself in a less
applicable way he said
but if by scientism we should mean the
view that the methods of the social
sciences are to a very considerable
extent the same as those of the Natural
Sciences then I should be obliged to
plead guilty to being an adherent of
scientism indeed I believe that the
similarity between social and the
Natural Sciences can even be used for
correcting wrong ideas about the Natural
Sciences by showing that these are much
more similar to the social sciences than
a generous supposed so what he said was
basically I am I follow scientism to a
degree because I believe that the
Natural Sciences and the social sciences
can interact
um he was less of a follower of
scientism than than what he admitted
somebody who was a follower of scientism
dogmatic Sciences as we discussed
earlier would be somebody who who sees
all the other fields of knowledge
whether it be sociology whether it be
philosophy whether it be even literature
and it can be governed by scientific
principles
whereas Carl popper said well they can
interact and kind of influence each
other that was really his his sort of he
had a weak form of scientism and you
know this is okay uh but he wasn't
dogmatic
as many people are today
let's go on to another gentleman
Bertrand Russell one of my favorites
uh died 1970.
um
he was right he was an atheist but he
was raised
I believe was his grandmother or her
mother is Christian uh he had a very
high ethical standard in fact he was one
of the first people I think if not the
first person to oppose nuclear weaponry
yep
one of the first people during his time
was like we should not be doing this is
very controversial for his period you
know today you think about it it's like
well that's common sense back then when
they first came out with it no he was
like this is horrible you should not be
using these weapons
and uh people didn't agree with him he
was chastised for that as well but he's
but he's a he's an atheist
you know we have we often have negative
opinions of atheists but you have to
understand about it
you know the Fifth Third is still there
for a lot of people even if they deny it
there there are a lot of people out
there who practice an ethical standard
because they're fit through a you know
is still it's still there it's still
very much in them
um it's trying to manifest itself and
Bertrand Russell is one of those
individuals who I can say with a great
deal of confidence even though I didn't
know him personally but from what I
could read from his writings and such he
was a very ethical individual and I have
high respect for him in that in that
regard because he was one of the first
people even before Christians were
saying these things he said we should
not have this sort of Weaponry this is
horrible and from an Islamic perspective
I don't I don't actually know the
history behind Islamic perception to
nuclear weaponry but I would assume that
that there was a lot of opposition to it
because of how horrible it was and how
and how it did not discriminate you know
against civilians
um
so yeah an atheist not a Christian was
the first to uh discuss this disarmament
of nuclear weapons
hey what's going to him
purely dogmatic scientism as we know
today had a humble beginning and
unfortunately he has to be credited for
this he didn't mean to do it though
at one point many philosophers believe
mathematics and numbers were synthetic
rather than analytic I'll discuss that
an analytical statement was that which
was true by definition whereas a
synthetic statement was one which
required verification external to the
subject so during his time uh
philosophers had this idea that there
are two types of statements
analytical statements okay and synthetic
analytical statements were just
statements that we make that are true by
definition so
um for example
a bachelor is a single man
that would be true by definition
okay a synthetic statement is the grass
is green
okay something like that
you understand something that can be
verified okay
based on experience
is exactly the same as what Kant talked
about Ahmed zeeshan
assalamualaikum
um he talked about more or less
experiences like
um
he differentiated between the
ontological
and phenomenal meaning like he what we
experience is not the thing as it is
um he would have been he would have made
the same distinction between synthetic
and analytical statements because they
weren't actually challenged until much
later
um so yes he did uh
yeah
I don't know why I went with a big
explanation but yeah it's true
um so it is very similar to what Colin
actually is mostly similar to what Kant
spoke about so this is very important
this is why you guys should learn
history history should be your favorite
class
aside from philosophy history should be
your favorite class
because it helps to explain
not only where you are today how you got
here and how we got here as a
civilization but also our ideas how our
ideas got here like you can't understand
Islam that much unless you understand
right the the Sierra the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam right you
can't you can't you just can't
you know I mean you can understand the
doctrines but you can't understand the
ethics or or why you know you don't
really have a true understanding of it
in the same way the idea is that that
you're surrounded by today you don't
understand them unless you understand
history
like you cannot understand the modern
world unless you understand what
happened in World War II because the
entire world that we have today was is
is exactly a reaction to World War II
the U.N the United Nations that that
thing that doesn't work you know that
exists because of World War II
right you guys need to reopen these
things if you haven't already
I sound like my father okay anyways
moving on
um so
he went on it went on to say uh
basically because each individual aspect
of every mathematical formula could not
be reduced to some of the whole outside
experiences given the immensity of the
calculations in question they had to be
synthetic statements so
um
so according to many philosophers during
Bert and Russell's time mathematics
mathematical like numbers themselves
were actual things
okay
I know that sounds weird to you but let
me just like if I write the number three
okay
this backwards okay awesome if I write
that that thing itself
is an actual thing floating out in some
Ideal World
that's how philosophers actually thought
about numbers that they're actual things
like you know physical objects
that we cannot seem to ascertain
uh they weren't things that you just
wrote down they were actual objects
um and they were floating around in some
ideal Realm so Bert and Russell thought
this was kind of silly
and he said he basically he would find
the solution to the problem of classical
mathematics being claimed to synthetic
by proving that it could ultimately be
reduced to logical axioms so he said
okay I don't think numbers are these
things floating around I think that they
can be reduced to logical axioms I think
if we if we broke down numbers
we would find out the end of the day
that it's all logic all numbers are
logic okay
and uh and then he would prove that they
were actually analytical meaning that
numbers were true by definition not by
being out there somewhere
um and if you're wondering like why they
were confused about this problem and why
this is an issue you're about to find
out
in other words he would prove that it
was merely a symbolic relationship too
but only by virtue of the definition of
place within thereby destroying the
claim of mathematics as being their own
separate reality
um and he did in his famous work
principle Mathematica he actually proved
that all mathematics can be reduced to
logical axioms
and that is awesome and I'll tell you
why it's awesome because
his work was the Foundation for Computer
Science
if we have any computer programmers in
here the reason that you have
programming language is because of him
the philosopher by the name of Bertrand
Russell if it had not been for his work
he would not have
C plus plus and whatever code you use
today because he proved that mathematics
was reduced to logical axioms
so give him credit for that he didn't
mean to do it but give him credit for
that
however by doing this by by proving this
uh he opened the doors for other people
to think about things in a different way
as well in not so good fashion
in the same way or the same vein Russell
opened the doors for other beliefs to be
challenged that were considered to be
synthetic such as the supernatural I.E
God so now are they thinking well if
numbers can be reduced to logical
statements
what about everything else that we can't
see and observe
right
let's move on next
this guy we come to Ludwig wisenstein
wittenstein wichtenstein
1951 the most eccentric person you will
ever meet in your life at least
according to his friends in his own
writings
um
he was also perhaps one of the most
arrogant people that ever lived but it
was a kind of a quirky way a funny way
uh he literally believed that he had
solved every problem in philosophy
after he wrote like 30 notes 30 pages of
notes
I'm reading oh yes
um
sorry just reading the the chat here so
he believed that he had solved all
problems of philosophy and uh what's
interesting is that him and um
Bertrand Russell were actually friends
and Richard wichtenstein was actually a
little younger than him
and um
he basically uh wrote these notes during
wartime he wrote them in in a
battlefield like when he was on his off
time he was writing his notes he was a
brilliant mind okay but he was very
eccentric very kind of crazy in his own
little way and very very he couldn't
even argue with him because he was so
like I am right you know you're wrong
um and uh human version used to be like
complete opposites of each other but
they used to get along for some reason
anyways so
um he wrote this work and he tried to
send it in to Virgin Russell he said
look I solved all the problems of
philosophy uh giving my PhD and Bertrand
Russell was like this this isn't this
isn't a thesis it's 30 pages of like
notes you know it was called attractus
and uh he denied Lucid wisenstein his
his uh his his PhD
and then eventually wisenstein was like
okay well since I solved all the
problems of philosophy I have nothing
else to do in life and he became a
grammar teacher
and um
then uh after that uh some philosophers
picked up his work and started using his
ideas and then Bertrand Russell was like
okay let's give this guy a PhD
and that was that
um
now it gets more funny after this too so
let's read this part first
a young philosopher contemporary to
Bertrand Russell who goes on to advance
a lot of his work included the following
from Virgin Russell so he read Bertrand
Russell's work and then he he improved
upon it and then he stated the following
okay let's see
another question first are The Logical
truths themselves a priori because they
are day two or analytic what makes them
so
a priori we're not going to discuss a
priority in here
uh this is more regarding like it'll be
in a future class
um I might answer that one later
okay so let's read what
uh he wrote in you know this is
basically his his thesis summarized
the right method of philosophy would be
this to say nothing except what can be
said I.E the propositions of Natural
Science I.E
something that has nothing to do with
philosophy and then always when someone
else wished to say something
metaphysical or non-observable
to demonstrate to him that he had given
no meaning to certain signs in his
propositions this method would be
unsatisfying to others it would have he
would not have the feeling that we were
teaching him philosophy but it would be
only it would be the only strictly
correct method
so basically what he was saying is that
uh nothing has any meaning essentially
unless it can be empirically verified by
scientific observation by science itself
um
okay another question uh before we go on
you guys are really throwing really good
questions at me
um
so let me read this one real quick
can we import scientific theories to the
Muslim world uncritically and teach them
in our schools or should there be a
review to ascertain their compliance
with the Islamic worldview
uh we will discuss that at a later Point
as well I I have prepared myself for all
of you guys you you have no idea
okay my mind works like clockwork
all right trust me we'll talk about that
um if your questions are in relation to
the material that I have here present
please ask it now so I can answer but if
it comes like if it's something that's
come in your back your mind like I want
to know this right now I don't care if
he gets to it or not yet please save it
for a little later and I will definitely
get into it like I'm not trying to avoid
your questions I promise
but you really need to understand this
part because this is very very very
important to understanding
uh how people think today okay so
after writing this the track of this
um he got his PhD and he basically
reduced all statements to analytical
statements
um
uh in other words anything lacking any
observable evidence based on science
should be rendered as meaningless
because statements can only have meaning
if they actually point to Something in
reality statements are only analytic and
without content otherwise so he
basically said that every statement that
you ever make is analytic until it can
be proven
that's it every statement you say
this is wichtenstein every statement you
say has no real content no no real
substance outside of its own definition
unless you can point to something
reality
okay
that's what he said so if you say
something like love
which in style would be like what is
that
like what are you talking about
where is it
does that sound like some of the
atheists you you talked to today
okay let's keep going
so let's get to AJ air
all right and he's going to be one of
the proponents of a movement that came
after Luther wisenstein because
witchenstein influenced a movement
after he made this this statement after
he made these claims he influenced a
movement called The Logical positivist
and one of the leading proponents of
logical positives with AJ air and we'll
get the word Quine and all that later so
let's go to AJR first
DJ air was a British philosopher one of
the leading performance of a movement
known as logical positivism he died in
1989.
foreign
individual
very quiet apparently he was always mad
um I know that's that's Haram but I was
telling you because he doesn't look the
type
um but he was um
he was very Charming person
and uh considered a gentleman among many
if I happen to recall I think he
actually got into a fight with
who was it
was it Mike Tyson not a physical fight I
think he got into a verbal altercation
with Mike Tyson
I'm not joking we can look it up uh
don't tell me how it happened it just
did
um okay so apparently Mike Tyson was
doing something bad
trying to impose himself upon a woman
and AJ air walked into the room during a
party and he said what are you doing
this is wrong and then he tried to talk
to uh Mike Tyson he talked him out of it
and apparently they became friends I
know it's weird just it's true though uh
so anyways
a British philosopher and one of the
leading proponents of the movement known
as logical positivism would carry on
witchenstein's views being the last boss
we're trying to defend the following
statement
so the statement he came up with was the
following we say that a sentence is
factually significant to Any Given
person if and only if he knows how to
verify the proposition which he purports
to express so basically he was saying
that no statement has any sort of
meaning whatsoever unless he can uh
verify that through some sort of like
you know
okay
uh some sort of uh what's the word
if it can be verified physically through
empirical observation okay
uh I have another question here
real quick for future classes please
give us some reading material before the
lectures so that's easier for us to
understand stuff when you were talking
I apologize
um I did uh send an introduction for
reading material I don't know if it was
posted on the website
that said
um it should be up there now I do
apologize in advance uh once again to
all of you
um I was actually extremely ill
a week ago I'm not trying to make you
feel bad but just bear with me I had a
minor heart attack
um last week so I'm just kind of like
recovering
um I know it doesn't look like they're
right yeah
um
that's because I'm so interested in the
subject
but um in any regard I do apologize
for that and I hope that
um like I said if you have any questions
regarding this material right now if you
need me to to to you know explain more
things please you know ask those
questions about this material so that we
can continue
um like I said if you're stuck on
something just ask and I'll do my best
to explain it to you
um
Okay so
yeah so that's what he said in other
words a statement has meaning if and
only if it can be empirically verified
by science or is true by definition
uh what air would fail to realize later
was that this very statement of
verification was self-refuting
and this is where it gets funny because
the entire philosophical School of
logical positivism would eventually fall
to pieces
uh because the very statement itself the
very thing in which they needed to
verify things the statement itself that
no statement has meaning unless it can
be empirically verified could not itself
be empirically verified
now there you go it's done right
self-refuting and he and throughout the
rest of his career he tried to solve
this dilemma it's like well okay well if
all statements are analytic and we can't
prove them
unless they can be perfectly verified
but the very statement itself or the
very claim the very claim of
verification itself cannot be verified
then what are we doing
okay uh next question what is
tautological
it means it's true by definition it's
just true
you know a single man is a single man
that's tautological
you see what I'm saying definitions in
and of themselves
something that is true by definition it
doesn't need any sort of external
sources
this is a good question uh
mean excuse me use syllogism is based on
pure reason to prove the existence of
God
so it's according to Liberal wittenstein
each proposition of the surgeon would
have to be proven empirically would this
mean that he would reject any proofs
with existence of God yes
and this is what the logical positives
did they rejected all metaphysical
assumptions every single thing you can
think of it doesn't matter
you could put the teleological argument
uh you could put the the cosmological
argument they looked at it and they said
it's not observable
we reject it it's meaningless
so let's see what happened
after they all realized now here's
here's an extra funny thing too by the
way I didn't mention the slides here
lutherstein would eventually reject his
own propositions he would eventually
redo his entire philosophy
um he would get rid of it entirely and
he'll be the first one to point this out
that there's a problem so
after all these years writing all these
notes you know doing it during wartime
and trying to get his PhD and saying
that he had solved all the problems he
eventually a couple years later he was
like uh hey guys I was wrong sorry my
bad
and then he fought against his own
philosophy
uh so that tells you something how
eccentric he was but he was a brilliant
mind
um
so let's but let's see how this
philosophy eventually got completely and
utterly destroyed it wasn't just because
it was self-refuting but it was
something else
and we're going to go now to the
American philosophers and this is about
the only thing I like about America are
the American philosophers and the
pragmatist tradition and we're going to
start with an individual by the name of
Willie Willard Quine who died in 2000.
and in the American tradition of
philosophy
um
it's very different from British uh in a
way it's like they focus on different
problems in the American version of
philosophy
it was more about practical things
um what can we use what can we do with
this you know what I mean whereas the
British philosophers were more like
trying to figure out issues of Truth and
justification and American proposal was
like look I just want something I can do
with it
okay
and you have to give them some credit
because the thing is they really broke
down what the problems were with is with
this philosophy
so let's see what will equine did
so despite the fact the principal
verification was self-refuting there was
more to argue against regarding logical
positives understanding of Science and
justification in general
will it Quine in American pragmatist
philosopher of science would eventually
show that the reductionist view of
science promoted by the likes of Asia
air was ultimately a flawed
understanding of science
okay so what is reductionist
he goes on to say the totality of our
so-called knowledge of beliefs is a
man-made fabric
this is a which impinges on experience
only along the edges okay so before
going into this more detail basically
Remember The Logical positivists believe
that nothing had meaning unless it can
be empirically verified so it had to
correspond with something outside right
statement corresponds with reality okay
so it'd be reduced so a statement could
literally be reduced into like the
smallest format unless if it could be
empirically verified so if I said
I have a lock on my door
okay all I have to do is show you the
lock on my door
okay that's it done you understand the
statement okay
but what Klein said was something else
he said look you can't do that
um
because statements aren't just
understood by what they correspond to
they under there there's more to to
understanding a statement or
understanding something in general than
just pointing at an object
so I'm going to give you an example okay
a statement
I need to fix the lock on my door before
I go to work today
very simple statement right
but it's really not if you think about
it
see let me try to reduce that statement
by asking a question
why do you need to fix the lock on your
door
I answered the question because my lock
is broken
I ask another question what do you mean
it's broken
well it you know it's it's broken it
doesn't lock anymore
I say okay why do you need to fix it
because I need to protect my things
while I'm gone why do you need to
protect new things you see where I'm
going with this
you can't keep reducing it it's
irreducible it keeps going around and
around because
within these statements that we make in
our daily lives there's more to
knowledge than what it corresponds to
directly in empirical observation
there's more to meaning than that
so
um
here's a personal example
uh when I was in I was living in
Malaysia for almost a decade doing my
studies there
and I remember I had I had some
neighbors from a rural part of Nigeria
okay
um
let me see here
a rural part of Nigeria and they didn't
have this concept of locks in their mind
um they didn't understand what locks
meant because well I learned this the
hard way I was um
I went out one day just to go get some
food I came back and I found out that my
door was open and
some of my stuff was gone like like my
kitchen supplies
like they were like they were gone I was
wondering why
and I found some of the kids
playing with them and I was wondering
okay what are you what are you doing
with my stuff you know and he didn't
understand he was one of he was one of
the children of my my Nigerian neighbor
he'd understand and you know this kept
going on for quite some time
and eventually I confronted you know his
father and I said look this has been
going on and you know I started locking
my door after that but you know
eventually you know I would unlock it
sometimes they would still come and do
things and I thought you know I just
want to tell you I'm sorry to say this
but you know
your son's kind of stealing from me no
offense I know he's young he doesn't
know any better but I just want to
inform you and you said oh I'm sorry and
he explained to me that the reason why
he's doing this is because in his
village in Nigeria
uh
the families there don't have locks they
don't they share the materials
they they go into each other's houses
and take things and come out you know
it's like it's normal
they even share the kids
and it's like for them the concept of a
lock is is very alien you know what I
mean so if you told them that statement
they wouldn't understand what you're
saying
um because their entire culture is not
based around this concept of privacy or
private property
in the west it's different you know we
have this concept
so in that way that kind of gives an
example that you can't reduce these
statements to anything because they're
within the context of a completely
different system of understanding and
this is what Klein pointed out he said
we don't live
in statements we don't live in in facts
that are you know just there and there
we live in this whole Web of Knowledge
that that contextualizes everything that
we say and do
right
um he would say that in other words
knowledge was holistic and
contextualized based on the world in
which we lived and understood things
so it can't be just reduced to logical
axioms you can't just say oh
you know we found it there it is
therefore it's all solved
because it corresponds our entire
interpretation of reality is is this big
web it's not just statements or words or
letters
right